well let's get the view from labor now
with the party's Shadow Home Secretary
Yvette Cooper
good morning Shadow Home Secretary
good morning Trevor
we heard from Penny mordant if I may
start with the Nicola bully
investigation that she shared the prime
minister's and home secretaries
concerned about that investigation uh
you told my colleagues here at Sky News
earlier on this week that you'd be
meeting the Lancashire police to discuss
the progress of the investigation what
what can you tell us about that
conversation
well this obviously is a very
distressing case and a family that have
a missing mum daughter wife it's a very
difficult case and my team had been in
touch with Lancashire police to have
more information but look at the heart
of this obviously the is the most
important thing is to try and find
Nicola bully in the handling of the case
obviously there was a lot of information
released and that was really unusual and
I think that's why there'd been so many
concerns as a result of this but what's
happening now is the information
commissioner has said that they're going
to investigate we've also had there's
going to be further internal reviews as
well I think the right thing now is for
those to take their course and perhaps
to have further discussion of this in
due course but at the moment for
everyone to support the Lancashire
police investigation to try and find
Nicola and also to support Nicholas
family who who must be in the most
unimaginable Agony as a result of what's
Happening
so you still have confidence in their
handling of the matter for time being
I think the most important issue at the
moment is the investigation into
Nicola's disappearance and I think
everybody should support that
investigation because that has to be the
priority
let's turn to the lead story of the day
I guess which is the
negotiations over the Northern Ireland
protocol
um your party leader has said that if
there is a deal which is Penny mordant
said this morning is supported by all
parts of the community there then labor
would
support it if necessary vote for
Relevant legislation do uh welcome what
has been happening recently
well I hope that a deal is imminent we
have been urging the government to act
on this for a very long time we've we
put forward ways and proposals as to how
that could be done so we really strongly
hope that a deal is imminent it is
strongly needed and yes as kirstama has
said we stand ready to support the
government to support Rishi sunakin
getting this through will provide
political cover for him if he has
problems within his own party on this
because this is in the National interest
to get this resolved and to get this
sorted both for Northern Ireland but
also more widely for the UK
this of course is all part of Labor's
policy of uh trying to make brexit work
now
can you imagine any deal
being acceptable to the EU that does not
involve the uh European court of justice
taking place at the moment there is also
an element already in terms of the role
that the ecj plays and I think that
seems to have become a sort of big
symbolic issue now for elements of the
conservative party the most important
thing really is to have a practical
program that works of course they have
to be dispute resolution mechanisms as
part of that but it's to have something
to work that just simplifies the process
for trade and we believe that there are
ways that could do that that actually
would be beneficial for the whole of the
UK as well as for Northern Ireland
including we've put forward proposals
around a Veterinary agreement that would
simplify many of the checks that are in
place but as you said this is about
making brexit work this is about being
very practical it is about getting
agreement and talking to people and for
a long long time the way in which the
conservatives have handled this is just
not to talk to anybody just to get into
standoffs just to get into rhetoric
rather than to actually be really
practical and have a common sense
approach to that but that's what we
would like to see
so to be clear the involvement of the
European court of justice in for example
the settlement of disputes over the
details of trade would not cause labor
any any problems in supporting a deal
there's going to have to be
process of course there is so we should
just be
pragmatic and common sense about
approaching that and I really really
hope that that is the approach that
ministers are taking and then they're
not going to just get all caught up in
really the sort of the approach that the
ERG that the sections of the
conservative party have taken to this
they've really got to be practical it's
too important to just end up walking
away when we need sensible measures in
place for Northern Ireland and for the
United Kingdom as a whole but that's why
we have said to Rishi sunak that if you
need support in Parliament we will be
ready to provide support in order to get
something through in the National
interest that's what it's got to be
about in the National interest not the
political rounds within the conservative
party
the political conversation is moving
rather decisively to a place in which
people are
seriously considering uh the possibility
of a labor government and um the your
leader in his speeches this week and I
guess the speech he will make today is
Scotland uh is beginning to sketch out
what labor would do so let's talk a bit
about what a labor government might look
like and talk about something very
concrete we can expect to see way with
strikes uh rail health workers teachers
and so on over the next few weeks and
months we know that the labor position
is that it would be great if the Tories
could get around the table and so on and
so forth so we don't need to go over
that
specifically
would a labor government in London make
the same offer to nurses as the labor
administrations in Scotland and Wales
are making to those workers
well we would get around the table and
negotiate where streeting has been very
clear about this from the start in fact
he's called on Steve Barkley he's called
on Richie's unit he's called on the
government to get round to the table
they really should be acting urgently
because nobody wants to see strikes
happen in the NHS least of all in fact
many of the nurses who are in such a
desperate situation they really want
something to be done so we should be
getting around to the table and
negotiating of course you don't conduct
those negotiations in public or on
television but we would be round the
table talking about paid talking about
conditions talking about the issues that
are affecting the nurses and the NHS
more widely as part of that we are also
being very clear we would increase the
training and recruitment of modern more
nurses more doctors as well and we would
cancel the unfair nondoms tax break in
order to put that money into training
the doctors and nurses we need because
if we don't get the additional Staffing
then the pressures on nurses on our NHS
staff are just going to continue and
that is really bad for patients so
without asking you so without asking you
to advance negotiating position the kind
of deal that Scots and Scottish
Administration wealth Administration are
offering would not be out of question
for you
well I think you are actually asking me
to conduct a negotiations around the
table and yeah I think everybody has
made clear that that's not the kind of
way that you do any negotiations it's
not the way that trade unions do
negotiations either but the whole point
okay let me ask you about that you have
to get around the table and be very
sensible
all right let me ask you a specific
question about
um uh Scotland
um Your Leader has said that he would
not have supported the snp's uh gender
recognition legislation the Scottish
labor party did and whipped its msps to
vote for it
would a labor government in Westminster
faced with a Scottish labor
Administration that wanted to pass this
legislation do what the Tories have done
and block it
well the whole point when you have
conflicting legislation again is to be
able to get round a table and resolve
the issues and that's what's happened
every time in the past so there are
different issues that the Scottish
Department the Scottish government can
legislate on there are other areas where
you have uk-wide legislation so for
example the gender reassignment
legislation that is something that
Scotland can legislate on but we also
have a uk-wide equality act that's also
important and that is the area that also
protects safe spaces for example for
biological women so where you have a
potential conflict between pieces of
legislation always in the past there has
been dialogue there has been a
discussion between the Scottish
government and the UK government in
order to find a way through this is the
first time that that has always wins
doesn't it has broken down and I think
well that's partly been because I think
the the reason that's broken down is
because there's been a sort of standoff
both the SMP and the conservatives
haven't wanted to have that discussion
so you have to have that discussion it
may be that you have to make changes in
the law in order to be able to
accommodate it but we think that is the
approach that you should take that is
the approach that we would take to any
disagreement with or any conflict of
laws with the Scottish Parliament okay
Yvette Cooper thank you very much for
your time this morning